Is there anyone alive in this world
currently who will not receive a single
gun in
Janam? If I understand the question
correctly, the question is asking that
is there anyone currently living who
will not get a punishment for singing in
Jenna? The answer is different. If the
question is is there anyone living today
who has not done a single sin, then the
answer is no. The only people who are
sinless are the ambia of the messenger
Allah subhanaa tala.
So I don't know of anyone living today
in the world who has not done a single
sin. But if the question is that is
there anyone who will not receive
punishment in the
ja inshallah there will be many. If
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala wants to
forgive someone even after he has
committed sin. If the person repents
inshallah Allah
is and there are various hadith in which
the prophet said that if the servants of
Allah sin during night and if they ask
for forgiveness in the morning Allah
will forgive them. If they sin the full
day and they ask forgiveness in night
Allah will forgive them. So if a person
does sin and if he repents sincerely and
there are two types of forgiveness one
is mak where Allah
forgives even Allah forgives on the day
of jment Allah will question you for
that sin but he will not punish you for
that because Allah has forgiven you
there's one type of forgiveness it
is so here The aura that is there is
forgiveness with removing any record
Allah will not question you. If Allah
forgives you in the higher level where
Allah will not question you. So the sin
you have done Allah will not question
you on the even about that. So that type
is a higher forgiveness. So is there any
human being who will not be punished in
Janum for a single sin? Yes, there'll be
many. Those people who repent to Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala and who are sincere
inshallah there'll be many. But if you
ask is there any human being who has not
committed a single sin now living on the
face of the earth then the answer is no.
of that solution.